regresa la crisis política a kenia tras
ser declarado perdedor de la contienda
electoral raila odinga rechazó los
resultados de las elecciones
presidenciales acusando al presidente de
la comisión electoral keniano de
despreciar la constitución de lo es que
la ley es clara sobre el rol del
presidente de la comisión la ley no
otorga al presidente los poderes de un
dictador para gobernar a la comisión
electoral independiente de manera
unilateral
el líder opositor perdió frente al
actual vicepresidente william ruto por
menos de dos puntos porcentuales
obteniendo un
48.8 por ciento de los votos según la
comisión electoral independiente
organismo que dirige o azul katy quien
también estuvo a cargo de los
2 de 2017 por el tribunal supremo debido
a presunto fraude en aquel tiempo
irregularidades denunciadas por el mismo
opositor raila odinga
las declaraciones de odinga son producto
de una desconfianza que venía sembrando
se y agravada luego de que cuatro de los
siete comisionados
desconocieran el proceso electoral
describiéndolo como opaco pero desde el
grupo de observación electoral
respaldaron las elecciones
a pesar de los desafíos de un curso y
las áreas claras para la reforma a las
elecciones generales de 2022 registraron
mejoras con respecto al proceso de 2017
y culminaron en un proceso mejorado y
abierto y un proceso de gestión de
resultados garantizados
kenia ha vivido históricamente episodios
violentos en medio de elecciones
causados por la competencia política
entre sus más de 40 etnias
el peor suceso se registró en 2007
causando más de 1000 muertos y unas
600.000 personas desplazadas por lo que
odinga pidió a sus seguidores mantener
la calma pero aseguró que utilizará
todas las vías legales y
constitucionales para impugnar los
resultados